right okay
um good evening councillors ladies and
gentlemen and welcome to this virtual
meeting of council
the first item on the tonight's agenda
is
all members of the council have been
invited to attendance this meeting
electronically and i've received
apologies for absence from the mayor
council of walsh
and councillors andy lam rigby and win
stanley
can i ask if anyone is aware of any
other apologies
i'll take that
you've just muted yourself though
sorry as you've heard unfortunately the
mayor has had to give his apologies for
tonight's meetings
and on behalf of the council i convey
our very best wishes to him
and to the mayor s may i first
remind you of a few house rules when
participating in tonight's virtual
meeting
please remember to mute your microphone
when not speaking
to use the chat facility to indicate to
the chair that you wish to speak
and please only use the chat room for
this purpose alone
to unmute your microphone when invited
by the chair to speak
voting also tonight on those items where
a vote is called
for we will use the polling option at
the appropriate time i will announce
that i am putting the matter to a vote
a window will appear on your screen and
you will be asked to click on one of the
three
options available either for against
or abstain once you have selected your
preference please click
submit at the bottom of the window
and the outcome of the vote will appear
on the screen once
all votes are in technical problems
finally since we are hosting the meeting
virtually should we encounter any
technical difficulties
it may be necessary to adjourn in the
first instance for 15
minutes an update and any rejoining
instructions will be emailed to members
if we are unable to broadcast the
meeting live on youtube
we would hope to upload a recording at a
later date
so we move to item one on the agenda
minutes the first item is minutes
and i move that the minutes of the
annual annual meeting held on the 25th
of november 2020
and the council meeting held on 8th of
december 2020
be taken as read and signed as a correct
record
is that seconded happened
thank you leader all in favour hi
hi
[Music]
i think we've taken the minutes as being
in order
[Music]
sorry um i'll start again
am i unmuted now because i'm using the
space bar to do that that's right
okay sorry holocaust memorial day
today is holocaust memorial day and i
along with other members
attended the council's online memorial
event this afternoon
may i now invite the council to pause in
reflection
and to commemorate those killed in the
holocaust and the genocides
the world has witnessed just for a few
moments thank you
thank you former councillor john
scofield it is regret
with regret that i informed the council
that just before christmas
former councillor john scofield passed
away
many of today's council would not have
met john
but he was a trafford councillor for the
then park
ward from 1975 to 1979
and prior to that he served on
stratford-borough council
for those that remember him they will no
doubt recall his passion
for education i invite the council to
pause for a few moments
reflection for his memory
the majesty of the queen's new year's
honours
may we take this opportunity to
recognize those citizens and persons
connected with trafford who were named
in her majesty the queen's new year's
honors list
this is joanne louise whitfield of
timperley who was awarded the cbe for
services to retail and the food supply
chain
during the covid19 response
this is sally jane deinwa of bowdoin
awarded the mbe for services to drama
dr amir simon hanan of hail barnes
awarded the mbe for services to general
practice
in hyde and horton green in the borough
of thameside
and mr nicholas peter spate of sale also
awarded an mbe for services to the food
supply chain
during code 19. i'm sure you will join
me
in conveying the council's
congratulations for their achievements
and richly deserved recognition
does the leader of the council wish to
make any announcements this evening
only very briefly mr deputy mayor
confirmed that in addition to
the holocaust memorial event that took
place earlier today
on behalf of all councillors i have lift
uh a candle outside the town hall
immediately prior to our um 6pm meeting
this evening
thank you thank you leader
do councillors acton dr barkley or
denise weston
have anything to announce on behalf of
the scrutiny committees
no mr mass okay can i just
uh say say quickly uh a few words
as members know there were two budget
scrutiny meetings held in december
uh we produced a report which has now
been submitted to the executive members
um and i won't repeat what i said
on monday but i hope that the executive
found the report helpful when
finalizing the council budget proposals
thank you mr matt mr deputy mayor
councillor barclay or councillor denise
weston
um nothing from me uh mr deputy mayor
just to say that hell scrutiny committee
recommends says
um tomorrow thank you mr mayor nothing
from me mr deputy mayor
um and the children young people
scrutiny committee
um recommences next week thank you
thank you councillors uh i can report
that
nine questions have been submitted for
tonight's meeting from councillors
welton
chilton evans butt new gross
miss blackburn minis and two from
councillor brothy
each questioner has the right of a
supplementary question
and all shall be put and answered
without discussion
we will now take the questions in the
order they were received
and i would remark that there have been
some written responses to some of the
questions
which have all been published for
members benefits
on the council's website and i would
hope that we can take those
answers as read thank you so question
one
councillor welton your first question
please
thank you very much deputy mayor um and
thank you very much
to the executive member for his written
response
to my question in follow-up i'd like to
ask her is the executive member aware
that there are also numerous physical
barriers on the transparent trail
that prevents its use by those riding
adapted bikes and trikes and
will he review these barriers to ensure
that it's accessible to all
thank you
councillor ad said are you able to
respond to a supplementary question
thank you mr zackie mayer and uh
councillor welton for your supplementary
question
uh yes i think we're we're crap to look
at that uh obviously these shoots have
been used extensively more so during the
recent during recent months uh and
and so obviously i think a lot of these
problems are beginning to come to light
if you happily send me those details
over after the meeting
i'll get those ways with the relevant
officers if you could please thank you
very much mr deputy mayor thank you
thank you councillor i've said question
two is from councillor chilton
thank you mr deputy mayor the
um and i'm more or less happy with the
response so for the sake of brevity i'm
happy to move on if you wish mr deputy
now
thank you councillor chilton so you're
accepting the responses you've received
thus far
are satisfactory for your requirements
question three
is therefore with councillor evans
please can you now put your question
uh well thank you uh deputy mayor i do
have a supplementary
question uh so thank you to the exec
member for the
uh the answer and and i do know the
success or the apparent success i
appreciate it's been closed for 12
months nearly
a view of the erston refurbishment
ermstone was a relatively up-to-date
building
at 1990 that had a full costing and
community consultation
altering them built 74 stratford pre-77
and parts of sales to date back to the
first world war
it appears we plucked from nowhere and
on cast
could you actually get to the point of
the supplement to it an uncosted option
the executive member must agree with me
that it is staffed to take this huge
decision for stratford and altering it
without associated costs including the
lack of ambition for
trafford will you please go back to the
drawing board and think again
dr patel would you respond thank you
thank you
deputy mayor um thank you uh
to council evans for your question um
your concern for the
financial pressures that the local
authorities under
is is most welcome we have an extensive
debate
um to the executive where i explained
that max associates and
leading industry specialists is working
through the costings and the technical
programming of the refurbishments of
ultraman
sale and stretford i'm not in a position
currently to
comment on the technical questions that
he asked about the age and condition of
those buildings but i will be
reporting back in future thank you
thank you councillor patel for your
response question four
is with councillor but thank you
thank you deputy mayor uh
my question is that leaving aside the
the dereliction of responsibility by the
gma
and andy burnham and his deputy mayor
beverly hughes to hold the gmp
leadership to account on its
systemic failure in recording the 80 000
crimes or so
including other crimes closed without
investigation seventy percent of all
domestic abuse cases
closed prematurely by the gmp will
counselor with them
offer an apost apology to residents of
trafford
for his part in the failure as the
appointed scrutiny member on the greater
manchester police fire and crime panel
to adequately question and scrutinize
committee
reports that he will have received and
on meetings held
particularly since the hmi cfrs
watchdog had reported concerns since
2016
and should have been a focus of
attention
would councillor whittem executive
member for communities and partnerships
just formed please thank you
thank you deputy mayor and thank you for
your question
councillor but all local councillors
will be rightfully interested in the
hmic
report and concern that the steps being
taken to address the findings of the
report are implemented
effectively councils will be aware that
since the publication of the inspection
report a number of measures
um have been announced including the
announcement of dedicated hotline to
support victims of crime which opened in
december
and the allocation to every award across
greater manchester of a named
neighborhood beat officer and the police
community support
officer i'm happy to speak to council
colleagues across the chamber subsequent
to tonight's meeting about the findings
of the hmic report the methodology
behind the findings what's happening in
the future in terms of further
inspections
and the measures announced by the mayor
and deputy mayor since the report's
publication
i'm also happy to speak about the work
of the police fire and crime panel of
which i recently
became a member and this is an important
matter of substance which i know
will be debating later on and because
we've got a motion on this uh
on this issue as well however if you've
read the text and and just heard
councillor books question he hasn't
asked the question um substance about
the the report or the issue
he's rather um chosen to take an
opportunity to engage in not
particularly sort of clever
um or subtle exercise in point scoring
so i have to say that even though
um you know this is an important issue i
think the question betrays councillor
but's lack of knowledge
um or interest in police governance and
scrutiny
it's interesting because when i saw the
question earlier this week i asked some
of my longer-standing council colleagues
whether the police fire and crime panel
or police scrutiny and governments more
generally was something that councillor
but had shown interest in
previously in the response i got from
colleagues was a resounding
no um but just uh to finish off given
that counselor book mentions the 2016
hmic report
i assume he's asked the same question
that he's asked me of former councillor
laura evans
who represented the the represented
trafford on the police crime
uh and fire panel in 2017 and 2018
and indeed as i've only been on the
panel for a few months
laura evans had much more time to
scrutinize the work of gnp
than i have had um to date like i say
we've got a motion on this issue
uh later on this evening and i look
forward to
councillor butt's apology for the 215
million pounds worth
of cuts to gmp gmp's government grant
since 2012
and the 2000 reduction in police
officers and the 1000 reduction in
police support staff that that caused
thank you thank you council with
councillor but do you have a
supplementary question
yes i certainly do and with that woolly
response i certainly do have a
supplementary
the fact that i think just to comment on
uh
saying that i have no knowledge i was on
the uh fire and rescue service for a
considerable number of
years i just wanted to make it
in that point i'm actually an ex-member
of the armed forces
i do point of order which should be
heard without counsellor but speaking
over me
so far mr mayor on a point of order we
have had a cv from councillor but rather
than a supplementary question
will a supplementary question be
forthcoming in accordance with the
constitution
thank you thank you thank you
yeah i want to ask the question but the
fact is you know
they're using this information in that
first point order mr mayor
dispense with a comment and move to your
question
right well given the complacency and
lack of attention on the gm police and
crime panel by the controlling labor
group
off on trafford council in the interests
of trafford residents and taxpayers
particularly after concerns were
highlighted in the report by the gm
police inspectorate
of uh can counsel with with them who has
a very poor attendance record on the
panel at least tell us then
how many or what percentage of those
around 80 000
unrecorded crimes relating to domestic
violence abuse were reported by
residents in trafford
it's a simple question right well
we got to the question eventually didn't
we counselor but and i happily provide
that information subsequent
to um tonight's meeting i mean just to
say i don't have a poor record of
attendance on that panel
i've only recently uh joined it and i
think again
councillor book portrays his lack of
knowledge of the working of the uh
the panel there with this question thank
you i think we
we have the question it is how many of
those 80 000
crimes are traffic crimes and i
understand you will be looking into that
and responding accordingly for which i
thank you
your first question please my first
question
in the wake of storm kristoff many
residents in templeley will have to fend
for themselves as emergency services
and amy were overwhelmed given the
likelihood that the climate emergency
will lead to increasing occurrences of
severe flooding
what strategic changes are the council
planning to make to ensure that
comprehensive flood prevention measures
are implemented
with input from affected residents
thank you councillor brophy please would
councillor ads head the executive member
for
environmental and regulatory services
like to respond please
thank you and mr mcgivern i've given
already supplied a very comprehensive uh
reply sent out emailed to councillor
both early state as well as being
published on the council website
hope that would be acceptable in that
sense because otherwise it takes me ten
minutes to go for it so if council both
is happy with that
we can move to the supplementary
i'm gonna take it councillor brophy that
you've received the
response from council ad said and we're
happy to move to a supplementary
question
thank you very much for counseling ted
for his very thorough
response i have received that response
and i'm happy to move to the
supplementary
question my supplementary question is on
this part of councillor ed said answer
that he said in his answer um at
trafford like many other areas across
the country we do not provoke fraud
prevention
as this leads to a misunderstanding of
what the council and its partners can
deliver
so i just want to address that
particular part
and so i think he's given some really
good answers in terms of
how we're going to improve as a
authority look at lessons learnt
and looking at member support and
involving
councillors as well as residents and
also
undertaking a section 19 flood
investigation so that's brilliant
but my question is we are concerned as
councillors in timperley that the
response time of over 24 hours to a
resident facing quite severe
studying it's not an acceptable outcome
and i just want to ask councillor ed's
head if he would write to simply
counsellors
so the issues arising from last week's
floods can be identified
and addressed because we just think the
residents need to
hear a bit more from trafford council
itself and i realize there are other
bodies involved but i just wanted to ask
councillor i said if you would
commit to writing a letter to the
timberly councillors and village
wardens as well thank you councillor
brophy council rad said
thank you mr mayor in the comprehensive
reply that i
that was sent out to council both indeed
members we set up very clearly uh
a lot the extent of the problems that we
had there
i mean obviously last week itself was
actually debi severing it's one of the
first times we've seen this in trafford
uh in certainly my time i think there
was actually a real danger to life and
limb
and i think we had a clear
prioritization order
in in which we'll actually deal with
those problems all their staff were
fully engaged
and honest with you i would actually
like to place on record
my own personal thanks on those on
behalf of other members who have said
similar
comments the way in which all their
staff and our partner organizations
actually performed on the night even
going beyond the duties what we could
have expected
to help perform this obviously the
floods have actually
done everything we could do and we have
got a prioritization order there
it comes to both you have some concerns
then please do let us know
particularly what they are after this
meeting and we can look at the film
obviously there is
and i have to review as is per my reply
i think quite frankly
i think we did everything we could and i
think suggesting that uh perhaps
that we didn't do enough i think is
simply unfounded
and not and i think simply do not accept
that as a position
i know many officers uh who actually
went out their way
i was involved in a number of things
during the day discussions with senior
officers from the top to the bottom of
the organization
i can tell you they worked tirelessly
during that time and they did everything
they could
when those prioritizations were there
was a real threat to life
and that above everything will take
first priority on an event like this
hope that council bulfy
will actually uh look at those
particular points there and obviously
after the event we are looking at
wider pictures as per my message and
there'll be many meetings to come
and that all council is crossable where
their awards have been affected
will be invited at certain points during
that this review to actually uh
have some input into that however
councilwolf who would care to actually
uh
send me that information particularly i
can see at that performance part of any
review
thank you mr mayor thank you councillor
uh question six is a second question
from councillor brophy would you care to
put your question thank you
thank you very much for the answer i've
just had to from councillor assert
um so my question number six is picture
academy
in temporary has been hit by the
flooding affecting their ability to
provide some outdoor space for
students as part of their agreed code 19
procedures
and colleagues will appreciate the
difficulties that any change in routine
presents
to these particular children their
special educational needs disability
children
the staff at peak so went above and
beyond sourcing their own pump from a
private firm
and clearing the water from their yards
and their playing fields
the concerns they raised with me were
what can the council do
to ensure that picture academy is
reimbursed for this unexpected cost
and support in the event of any future
flooding
thank you councillor brophy i understand
that councillor carter the lead member
for education
is to respond thank you thank you mr
deputy mayor and thank you councillor
brophy for bringing this matter to my
attention
the clue here is in the name picture
academy is an academy
school so that means that it's free it's
funded by the state
and it gives heads and teachers you know
a lot more greater freedom to run
schools because they are no longer part
of an la
as in la we do work closely with the
sovereign trust of which picture is a
member
and we're happy to give them more any
support
when it's requested but this does not
include financial support
as the government would expect the trust
to provide that to the school
the site was visited prior to storm
kristoff
to investigate flooding reported by
residents flying
grove and the allotments no work could
be done
on the culvert until the water receded
and
as such staff highlighted that if any
sandbags were required by residents and
they would be provided
staff visited land grove during the
incident to check the water levels
and they pose no risk to the properties
members of staff looked at the issue
with the academy and attended but once
it was found to be purely the playing
fields they had to prioritize other
residents
as you would rightly expect thank you
thank you councillor carter uh
councillor brophy do you have a
supplementary question
thank you very much yes and i just thank
council carter for her response
my sublimity question is around and it
is linked with the other question as
well it's about schools and residents
expectations
i can appreciate that travel council
isn't responsible for everything that
happens in trafford but in terms of
working with our partner agencies
at schools and residents there is an
expectation that
information is provided and i do think
that
in terms of that you know you've
obviously been to visit it but
this is a long-term problem and um the
flooding with climate change emergency
is only going to get worse
in timperley and in everywhere of
trafford i think my
question gets deeper than this my
supplementary question is
to counsel carter how are we going to
make sure that
our schools and our institutions who are
part of trafford are better prepared in
the future because clearly
this took picture academy it wasn't
expected
and they felt quite unprepared so
how we're going to make sure trafford
works with our partner organizations
to make sure that our institutions and
our residents are better prepared in the
future to respond to events which
are likely to become more frequent in
the future
um thank you councillor brophy um if if
i could be so bold i don't necessarily
think that's an education question
i um and you know um council radzed's
team would be better at
answering that than i would if i'm
honest
you know i have said that we have
partnerships and certainly
we work very well with all the special
needs schools this was a
once in a hundred years um flood we were
led to believe last week and i do
appreciate it was really bad over in
in temporally and and in many other
areas of the borough
um but i think it would be up to the
environment team to look at flood
defenses and the solution to that rather
than the education team
thank you
deputy j you're muted as well
sorry deputy mayor you're muted
deputy mayor you're muted
i
for which there is a response already on
the traffic website
and i wonder whether he wished to move
straightway to the supplementary
question
i would like to thank councillor ads
head for his
answer and the residents that contacted
me on crummell road
norwood road hillingdon and longford
park area
are very happy with the answer thank you
okay so we move to question eight which
is from councillor miss blackburn
for your question please thank you mr
deputy mayor thank you council ads head
for your
response to my question regarding the
cycle lanes on
lost total road the residents will be
very interested in your response
my supplementary question is can counter
ads head confirm whether he plans to
create designated
cycle lanes on winchester road debut
between
mossvale road and crossbank road
thank you council don't miss blackburn
uh once again councillor ad said please
would you like to respond
thank you mr deputy mayor uh obviously i
think
council blackburn is referring to the
work that's uh going to go forward over
the next few months on the ernst
active neighborhood which are not
connected to the uh
the ballard scheme that was actually on
lost road uh i can't confirm anything at
this point because obviously the
consultation has just finished
and work with local councillors and
other agencies including residents
will be the next stage now where we
actually work on that so i can't give
anyone what will happen the decision
will be with local councillors
and with members who actually be
deciding these things over the next few
months possibly uh next year or two
obviously that time has all got to work
so we don't know exactly
because the effects are called with the
extent of it all but certainly no
decisions i've been making i think
you've already seen this information
information has been sent out to many
residents across
the uh many parts of irmston and did uh
part of the work i have done over the
last several weeks is to actually
ask the amy team to actually put in a
dedicated person
who who so will be to actually
help respond to residents queries and
problems and issues
arising out of any concerns from any of
the earnest and active neighborhood
obviously there are no decisions we make
i mean and any mischief making those
areas is simply not helping things
and i think that's quite clear in this
once concerns have been raised because
of misinformation put out by some people
around the area
and i think it that is irresponsible and
it could affect the neighborhood
work that we're hoping to achieve with
some very uh potentially good ideas out
there but
i'd like to assure the member that
nothing has been decided at all
and and all that you've done over the
next few months i'd like to place it on
record if possible mr mayor please thank
you
thank you councillor outside for that
response uh the final question is now
with councillor minis thank you
thank you mr deputy mayor my question
it was um the trafford all age transport
policy
was up for consultation over the
holidays and i was quite disappointed to
find the consultation comprised of only
two questions
um and it didn't give any opportunity
really for
any anyone to engage in asking for any
further suggestions could i gain
a commitment from the executive that
further consultations are both
complete and meaningful please thank you
thank you councillor minis uh would
councillor carter lead member for
education
uh care to respond to this question
please thank you
thank you very much deputy mayor i would
indeed um
can i stop you there councillor minis
the consultation lasted for eight weeks
six of that was during term time two
weeks over the holidays
so detailed information was produced to
explain the current policy
what the changes were going to be and
there was a thorough analysis of
families and schools that would be
affected the consultation was promoted
by
writing directly to all the families who
would be impacted by the proposed
changes
to wider families via all the primary
and secondary schools and also on social
media
consultees were asked if they agreed
with the proposal and they were invited
to ask questions
make comments or share alternative ideas
there was a supplementary question about
whether the low-income criteria should
be expanded to include more families
meaningful consultation gives careful
consideration to the comments made
during the consultation process and
responds accordingly
a process that's still underway in
addition to the
specific trust transport consultation
a question on the proposed change was
included in the budget consultations
um as a way of seeking wider input
for this wider consultation 69
of the 441 consultees
strongly agreed or agreed with the home
to school transport proposal
i would like to thank all the officers
involved who carefully plan these
consultations
promote them and develop written
responses to all the comments and
suggestions
the approach is to be applauded and is
completely robust
thank you
thank you uh council carter the council
of
you have a supplementary question
yes i do thank you so much for your
response and
counselor carter um uh the
the consultation you're absolutely right
it went for it was a longer period
um but it was also included the holidays
uh what i was going to
ask uh so the thing was that it the when
you're saying that um
a consultation was open obviously was
advertised
a lot of people didn't manage to engage
fully but my actual question my
supplementary question was is
concerns the transport um policy
so whilst trafford transport policy is
compliant with national guidelines
um would you be able to tell me um
why children who attend special schools
and should qualify for the transport
um are being denied it and being quoted
the three-mile policy which is
for the more for more abled children
thank you
um thank you thank you council minister
can i ask you to send me the details of
the individual cases because that's not
my understanding
so i'm more than happy to take up
individual cases that you know of
thank you i will do thank you thank you
councillor carter for that response and
as council ministers said she
was appreciative of the response and
your likely future
response to it we move to item four now
on the agenda which is membership of
committees and
outside bodies in addition to the change
to the membership
of the greater manchester waste and
recycling committee detailed on the
summons
the council is also asked to note that
as of now councillor bunting
is replacing councillor rigby as a
member and opposition
spokesman on planning and development
management committee
does the council note these changes
please
hi hi hi
hi hi hi
thank you uh item five corporate health
and safety report
uh the six-month corporate report on
health and safety
and i invite councillor ross the
executive member for finance and
governance
to introduce the report councillor ross
thank you mr deputy mayor kobit 19 has
brought significant challenges in
protecting our workforce whilst
continuing to
deliver key services this report
therefore
highlights the key work undertaken or
supported by the health and safety team
a brief overview of incident data and
ongoing delivery of support
a key area of covered work includes
supporting our staff to work from home
putting into place covert secure
building arrangements the development of
guidance and individual risk assessment
templates for services in schools
supporting the public health test and
trace team in responding to notified
suspected or confirmed covert cases
in the work environment supporting
schools with covert 19 template risk
assessments
the health and safety team have also
supported our services with access to
ppe
and throughout the pandemic there's been
a particular focus on mental well-being
amongst our staff
in terms of accidents we've seen a
significant reduction from 70 to 20 due
to more staff working from home
pausing of some services changes in
delivery reduced walk-in customers
and schools initially only open to key
workers
in terms of other work the report has
highlighted the significant work that
has been delivered in response to covid
to protect our workforce whilst
continuing to deliver our services
the work will continue into 2021 and the
performance detailed further in the nga
year-end report i'd like this to be
noted thank you very much
mr deputy mayor thank you councillor
ross
for that report i have an indication in
the uh
chat room that councillors evans and
maya's wish to speak would anyone else
wishing to speak please
also note in the chat room and i'll call
upon
councillor evans to speak first of all
apologies uh deputy mayor my comment was
for item four because on the actual
agenda it didn't mention council of
bunting so
that's fine thank you i apologize thank
you council
evans so we move on to a comment from uh
councillor myers on this particular item
item
five thank you uh thank you mr deputy
mayor
uh just to say we welcome the report
it's a very good report under the
circumstances it's been a difficult six
months
i suspect the next six months will be
equally difficult as well
and i'd like to thank the officers for
all their work that they've done thank
you
thank you councillor myers i can see no
other
comments in the chat box and therefore
this report being for information
can it be noted please i
[Music]
thank you um item six motions
the evening has six motions listed on
the summons
and they are in the order in which they
were received
to get through the business and to give
everyone who wants
an opportunity to speak it may be
necessary to limit the time for speeches
so we begin motion six a the motion
regarding poverty emergency
is to be moved by council of whittem
please thank you
thank you deputy man
mr deputy mayor between 1997
and 2010 both pensioner and child
poverty
in the uk fell by over one million
these gains were made through a
combination of tackling chronic low pay
major employment support programmes for
groups such as the over 50s and single
parents
and through the introduction of
well-targeted benefits such as working
tax credit
child tax credit and pension credit
these measures were underpinned by
policies such as sure start that sought
to address the long-term disadvantages
people living in deprived communities
faced
importantly when the global financial
crash hit in 2008 the labour government
took steps to shore up the support
provided to low income families
so they wouldn't have to pay the price
for an economic crisis they didn't cause
this is in marked contrast to what
happened on the conservative and lib dem
coalition
government between 2010 and 2015.
by 2010 things weren't perfect there was
still much work to be done but the
progress in tackling poverty and related
issues was something precious that
should have been built upon
fast forward 10 years and what's
happened those gains have been thrown
away
disregarded by a government that has no
national strategy for tackling poverty
this government has scrapped the child
poverty targets introduced under labour
and has scrapped the requirements on
local authorities to have poverty
strategies in place
over the last 10 years and this is far
from an exhaustive list
we have seen educational maintenance
allowance scrapped child trust fund
payments scrapped benefits such as child
benefit child tax credit universal
credit restricted to the first two
children
in a family we've seen working tax
credit
cut we've seen working age benefits
frozen between 2016 and 2020
taking millions if not billions out of
the pound of pounds out of the pockets
of low income families
and even support provided through the
government's own flagship welfare policy
universal credit
has been cut back since it was first
announced
the consequences of this government's
failure are clear for all to see pension
of poverty is on the rise and child
poverty is projected to reach levels not
seen since the
early 1990s over the coming years
on our streets scores of people sleep
rough and thousands more in temper
accommodation or sofa surfing
appallingly we find ourselves in a
situation where millions of food parcels
have been given out to people each year
because they don't have enough money to
put food on the table
we have over 200 food banks or other
food a projects in greater manchester
alone
what an awful indictment that is on the
conservative government and i think it's
just worth saying that if we go back 10
years
we didn't have food banks in the way
that we do now here in greater
manchester or
in other parts of the uk conservatives
might point to isolated
positive measures such as increases in
the national minimum wage or
improvements in child care support but
let's just be absolutely clear
any positive measures taken over the
last 10 years are far far
far outweighed by the 37 billion pounds
worth of cuts
to working age benefits cuts to public
services and cuts to local council
budgets since 2010.
conservatives will no doubt say that the
best way to tackle poverty is to create
a strong economy
of course it is but you have to create
an economy that works for everyone
they'll say that work is the best route
out of poverty failing to acknowledge
that two-thirds of working-age adults
and two-thirds of children
living in poverty are in households
where at least one person goes out to
work the majority of the cuts to working
age benefits over the last 10 years
some of which i mentioned earlier have
hit working households
conservatives may also point to some of
the additional support that's been
provided to households during the
pandemic flossing over the failure of
the benefits system to adequately
adequately support people
prior to the covert 19 crisis
it is in this context that we're
declaring a poverty emergency tonight
one of the first councils in england to
do so
the uk government has absolved itself
with the responsibility for dealing with
this issue
and it is our responsibility to do two
things as a result
firstly to raise awareness of the scale
of the issue joining with others calling
our government to introduce
urgently introduce a uk-wide poverty
strategy
and improve the financial support that's
provided to low-income households
through the
social security system secondly while
recognising the main levers for dealing
with poverty lie with central government
as a council we will do what we can to
prevent and reduce poverty
as well as mitigating against the worst
effects of central government
policy and i'll just remind people as i
said earlier there is no
statutory requirement anymore on
councils to have poverty strategies in
place but as people will know
we recently introduced a one-year
poverty strategy and we plan to build on
that
by working with partners across the
public private and voluntary sectors
to develop a long-term plan for
addressing the issue locally
we will maintain a strong local welfare
offer through traffic assist the council
tax support scheme
and through the provision of benefits
advice and welfare rights services
as we recover from the pandemic we will
also support a vibrant and inclusive
economy
that supports the creation of good
quality sustainable jobs
i take no pleasure uh mr deputy mayor
whatsoever
in having to move emotions such as this
um but as an administration we cannot
sit idly by
as the government fails to to get a grip
of this situation and i think that's
been best
embodied by the the sort of on-the-hoof
approach to policy-making in respect of
free school meals that we've seen over
over recent times we're facing a poverty
emergency and with child poverty
projected to reach 37
by 2023 exceeding the previous record
high of 34
in the early 1990s we have to treat this
issue with the urgency it deserves
if we don't children will continue to go
hungry pensioners will live in cold
homes millions will fail to realize
their potential and we'll
all be the worse off for it thank you
deputy men
thank you for that proposal is the
motion seconded
it is mr mayor uh mr mayor like
councillor whittem it gives me no
pleasure to second this motion
and before kobed there are already 14
and a half million people
in poverty in the uk 4.2 million of
those were children that's a rise of six
hundred thousand since
2010 and half the people living in
poverty
are disabled or live in a household with
somebody who is
before the pandemic well over half of
people living in poverty lived in a
household where at least one adult was
in work
there was the tory benefits freeze from
2016 to 2020
but for three years before that the
rises were also limited to one percent
that's seven years of benefits cuts in
real terms
where the increases failed to keep pace
with the cost of living
pre-coded wages were falling and they
were falling the fastest for those on
the lowest pay
so we cannot blame the pandemic for
poverty but we can blame
this and recent tory governments
many of those struggling to keep their
heads above water before covid
have now seen themselves pulled under
four of uh four in ten people who were
working at the start of 2020
are now in a household with no earnings
and 45
of those who are still in work have seen
their incomes fall
those groups who've already been
struggling the most to stay afloat
have borne the brunt of the impacts of
cobit
part-time workers black asian and
minority ethnic households lone parents
private renters social renters have all
seen larger rises in
in poverty levels and 25 percent of
disabled people
report having less money available for
food compared to 12 percent of
non-disabled people
some of those struggling have been
thrown a lifeline by the government's
furlough scheme
and by the temporary increase in
universal credit
of 20 pounds a week but the government
is currently intending to pull those
lifelines away
by april i know the government faces
huge challenges in managing the economy
through the disruption of covid
i don't underestimate that making the 20
pen dot uplift permanent would cost
6 billion pounds which is a large sum
but remember the government was willing
to spend 8 billion pounds
on contracts with companies connected to
tory politicians
or with no relevant previous experience
in many cases delivering ppe that was
useless
the tories have a problem with poverty
and they have a problem in tackling
poverty
from george osborne strivers and
shirkers to ben bradley's crackdowns and
brothels
they cling on to their dickensian notion
of the deserving and the undeserving
poor the government had to be dragged
kicking and screaming to provide
assistance to children at home
who would normally receive free school
meals and of course we remember that
they voted against it in parliament
i'm proud that in trafford we've helped
those in poverty during this pandemic
through trafford assist our network of
response hubs
and the free school meals assistance but
i'm sure we'll see in the budget meeting
next month that will still
will still be waiting for the money
promised by the prime minister to local
authorities
to do whatever it takes we are in a
poverty emergency
but the government has no plan to deal
with this thankfully here in trafford
under labour we do the adoption of this
motion
on the back of trafford's poverty
strategy will ensure that we as a
council do what we can to help our
residents in poverty
and that we plan ahead to lift them out
of it we will give people in
in poverty dignity by having their
voices heard through the poverty truth
commission
but we cannot do this alone which is why
we're calling on the government to
introduce a uk-wide poverty strategy
to build an economy that works for all
with high quality and well paid jobs
and to plan ahead as we're doing in
trafford for a future free from
coronavirus
and a future free from poverty thank you
mr deputy mayor
thank you i would point out at this
point that we
have the six motions and the approximate
time for each
is probably less than 20 minutes we've
had 16 minutes already
of the proposal and seconding on this
one and we have
six people so far in the chat room who
wish to speak
so i would ask you to be relatively
brief and
certainly not to repeat anything which
any of your colleagues may have said so
in order
now can i call upon counsellor new to
speed thank you
thank you mr deputy mayor i'd like to
speak in support of the motion moved by
council of whitten and seconded by
councillor hartley
i feel it's essential to do so as i am a
war councillor for buckley st
martin alongside councillors wright and
williams
with regards poverty and deprivation
butler award ranks first
out of all of trafford's 21 wards the
first being the most
deprived the most up-to-date source of
relative deprivation
data dated 2019 shows that we rank
490 out of 32
844 lower layer super output areas or
ls oas facts has taken into
consideration in this data
are income employment education skills
and training
health and disability crime barriers to
housing and services
including accessibility to housing and
local services
in a world where public transport is
notoriously poor and has been for
decades
and finally the living environment these
statistics are a grim read
but to then factor in the additional
impacts upon the war by the
covid pandemic job losses lockdown
months of shielding death more
reliance on our food banks universal
credit and other benefits
children and young people unable to
access education and a high percentage
without adequate means or devices to
assist with home learning
teenagers unable to attend college
places and universities despite
and universities despite still being
charged for their student accommodation
we cannot ignore the crippling impact
upon the mental health of our
communities as a whole
in part due to poverty of finances
decimation of services
and ultimately the poverty of a lack of
meaningful interaction with other people
naturally with this in mind i 100 agree
with both earlier speeches and i support
this motion fully and thank you mr
deputy mayor
thank you council and you um next
speaker is councillor procter thank you
thank you deputy mayor i'd like to start
off by saying
almost 35 years ago i was a new mum i
had a small baby
and a husband counselor kevin proctor he
lost his job
and we had to be on benefits for quite
some time
but we managed we had just enough to get
by
it's not the same anymore people are
having to use food banks on a daily
basis
in trafford within trafford we've got
nine
at least nine food banks
from the government report the house of
commons briefing paper food bank in the
uk
earlier last year they found
that there's been a massive increase
107 increase in the number of children
needing support from a
food bank in april last year compared to
the year before
they found 177 increase in the number of
emergency food parcels
in may last year compared to the year
before
126 increase
in april last year it's shocking the
impact that
furlough kobe 19 has had on people in
this country
when the benefits now aren't enough to
survive on
not live and enjoy life but just
to survive and we've had information
saying almost
5 million uk adults have had to rush in
their meals
or have had no access to healthy foods
south trafford food bankers found that
one in five people in trafford lived
below the poverty line
one in five of us
as i've said we've got at least nine
food banks
and they have distributed over 4 000
food parcels
to people in trafford two thirds of
those two adults are third
to children even trafford housing trusts
advertise on their website where people
can access food banks in trafford
the itv found that there's been a 100
increase in the need
for food banks in the pandemic the
furlough wage of
percent isn't enough you can't pay
eighty percent of your gas
or eighty percent of your electricity
and people are having to choose between
doing that and buying food the five week
delay
and deductions to the payment rates in
universal credit has meant there's not
enough
money to survive with basic needs
like me and kev and our daughter did 35
years ago
now you're making a choice of eat or
heat
pay your bills have enough food
people are going without food children
are going out without food
and that is something utterly shameful
in the fifth or sixth
richest country in the world that
people are going hungry and being forced
to use food banks
and that's wind up now okay
and that's down to the tory government
and its policies
we have a poverty emergency a
possibility
crisis in the comp this country we've
never known before
thank you thank you councillor shirley
procter i've allowed the two speakers a
little longer because they had given me
advanced notice yesterday they wish to
speak on this we've now have
five more people so i'll move to council
and minis please
thank you mr deputy mayor um i'd like to
offer my support on behalf of the
liberal democrat group
for the aims of this motion i think it's
absolutely right that when we refer to
an issue like poverty
we use terms like emergency because the
reality is that in 2021 far too many
people in our society
still face barriers to opportunity
lockdown has compounded issues like
overcrowding lack of outdoor space
lack of access to the internet and
technology required for home schooling
schools and in particular teachers have
risen above and beyond
to provide for their families with
little to no notice
they really have shown we have seen a
fiasco
from the government on free school meals
that's led to unnecessary stress and
hardship
for some of the most vulnerable families
in our communities
we live in one of the richest nations on
earth yet our government allows the
children to go hungry mr mayor we know
the positive
effects on attainment motivation and
mental well-being that a good school
mill provides they manage it in finland
france and sweden it's a travesty that
the government has let children
in this country down at this crucial
time
there's clearly a need for us to address
the issue of whether or not we're a
caring society
and this motion speaks to that need of
particular concerns on mental health and
opportunity for young people here in
trafford
firstly on mental health it's critical
that support is made available
in areas where there are higher levels
of deprivation particularly relating to
housing
i would also ask the administration to
look closely at extracurricular learning
opportunities
to ensure that children from less
affluent backgrounds are receiving the
same opportunities
to explore music and drama as their more
well-off classmates
we know how beneficial art subjects are
to a young person's
mental state and personal development
yet it tends to be these areas where
barriers exist
because it is expensive to learn an
instrument or time consuming to get a
child
to a drama class when parents are
working full-time so with these
considerations attached i offer my full
support to this motion thank you
thank you councillor minis uh next call
upon councillor dr
carr thank you thank you mr deputy mayor
i will be brief but as a doctor
um i had to speak on an issue that is
fundamental to health
the increase in child poverty is not
just sad at his harrowing
these children are losing their futures
their life expectancy is being reduced
they will grow up with health
inequalities and be many times more
likely to be affected by chronic ill
health
children who are hungry cannot learn
they cannot play
they are far more likely to suffer from
anxiety and mental health problems
it is shocking and awful that this
motion is necessary
but we must act to help both children
and pensioners in poverty
thank you thank you councillor carl next
speaker is councillor slater thank you
thank you uh mr deputy mayor
at exec on monday we agreed the um
equality strategy and
we agreed that that needed to be ready
in conjunction with the
um poverty strategy and it's shameful
that in the 21st century that we are
having to actually declare a poverty
uh crisis we are one of the wealthiest
boroughs in gm and it is
it's it's absolutely disgusting that
this has happened having to happen today
the tory government and their coalition
partners were the architects of this
crisis
and our colleagues across the chamber
should be lobbying government to get
their government to do the right thing
there was money for dido harding and her
failed track and trace system
there's money for lord ashcroft a tory
donor and former chairman of the
of the tory party uh for his to take
over the vaccination program now
well actually what we need is we need to
go where people need it where people are
hungry
we need we need the government to do the
right thing
and i remember you know when we were
having the election last in december
2019
the promise from the tory government was
that we would level up
and this is not happening the tory
government now needs to
be held to account and they need to
level up and our and poverty needs to
end and it needs to end now
thank you thank you councillor slater
next speaker council of myers please
thank you
thank you mr deputy mayor um i'm very
glad to see
uh the paragraph that's been put into
this motion on our local welfare
offers um our council tax support scheme
costs 12 million pounds a year but it
remains the most generous in greater
manchester
and among the most generous in the whole
of england
this was a deliberate strategy when the
conservative administration
launched the scheme back in 2013 and i'm
very glad
that the labour group are not trying to
amend the scheme at this stage
i should also like to take this
opportunity to thank the traffic assist
team
for the work they've done and the work
that they will continue to do thank you
mr mayor
thank you councillor myers and uh
councillor evans
wishes to comment thank you thank you
thank you deputy mayor
uh the conservative group in trafford
recognizes the action to alleviate
poverty is always welcome but this
motion falls way
short of that and unfortunately does not
advance actions that will make a
material difference
the government's over the past 10 years
have done more to support low-income
households than those that went before
it the introduction of the national
living wage
as alluded to by councillor whitson
earlier and
most importantly lifting millions
of pay out of paying any income tax at
all with the raises in the personal
allowance
it is simply false to state that these
things haven't directly
assisted low-income families the
government has spent
208 billion on business and employment
support alongside other measures to
support the economy
families and employers throughout the
pandemic is patently untrue
that level of support is a drop in the
ocean and is clearly not sustainable
conservatives call for greater support
for a sustainable growing economic
recovery
not underpinned by unsustainable levels
of welfare
because this um motion will make no
material difference
where our group will not be supporting
it
thank you mr mayor mr deputy man thank
you councillor evans
um council of wisdom has the right of
reply and
i would ask you if possible to be brief
in your
summing up council at whitman thank you
yeah thank you mr deputy mayor conscious
of time we'll keep it brief
just just want to thank um all those
counsellors who
contributed constructively um to the
debate we've just had on on the
motion agree with and welcome and lots
uh that was
said i i must just pull councillor evans
up quickly
on on something there i mean i did say
and i said this really clearly
intentionally in my speech at the
beginning because
any positive measures introduced over
the last 10 years
have been far far outweighed by the cuts
to benefits and cuts to public services
and it's really important that we
consider these things in the round
one of the reasons why it's so important
to have a poverty strategy
because the lack of one means we take
individual decisions
which may result in some good but at the
same time we do loads of other things
that really damage people
push them into poverty and compound the
hardship and deprivation
that we're we're facing in this country
so having that in place is really really
important
other thing i must say as well of course
councillor evans was at the exec meeting
where we
passed the poverty strategy in in
december and
i'm sure he read the strategy and could
see that there was some
uh real substance in there and it
provides the sort of pathway we need in
the borough
in the absence of having a poverty
strategy and under the previous
administration
to really take steps at a local level
that will make a substantial
difference to people and one final uh
final point just on on the
um the personal tax allowance it's a
regressive measure
most of the benefits and by the way the
increase in the
is in the personal tax allowance have
cost billions of pounds
most of the benefits of that measure go
to
middle and higher income households and
it doesn't benefit
those people whose income is already
below the personal tax allowance level
which is lots and lots of people in this
country so actually it does
nothing to benefit the very poorest and
i think it's important that people
understand that thank you deputy mayor
thank you council whitam in your
i will now put the motion to the vote
so please will you indicate
appropriately
so i don't get to
please make sure that you do click on
submit at the bottom of the box
otherwise your vote's not going to get
into the
[Music]
people's place
is carried thank you so we move to
motion 6b um
the second motion concerns the all-party
parliamentary group definition of
islamophobia and it's in the hands
initially of counsellor london thank you
thank you very much deputy mayor
in order for all of us here today to
understand islamophobia
and for this council let's play in
defeating it
we must quickly consider its causes
islamophobia has existed for centuries
since the crusades and colonialism
when it was used extensively to justify
the domination of others overseas
since the collapse of the soviet union
in the early 1990s
we saw islamophobia write its head again
in the resulting power vacuum
the military industrial corporations
many a politician and commentator
have been all too happy to ensure that
samuel huntington's 1992 clash of
civilizations thesis
became a self-fulfilling prophecy as he
identified
the islamic green peril as a likely
replacement for the defeated
communist red peril the resulting 21st
century's war on terror
has played out on the ground in
afghanistan iraq the caucasus
eastern and central africa more recently
xinjiang in china
killing hundreds of thousands of
innocent men
women and children most of the muslims
the victims of this not so new
geopolitical war have been felt far and
wide by people of every nation and faith
including here in greater manchester
when on the 22nd of may 2017
a manchester man claiming to be a
follower of islam
murdered 23 innocent people
in the days and weeks that followed that
hideous attack
when i agree for the victims was raw and
our anger at the perpetrator d
greater manchester police reported a 505
increase in the number of islamophobic
hate
incidents in that figure mr deputy mayor
we see the most obvious and dangerous
consequences of islamophobia
here at home in greater manchester that
is the blaming and targeting of innocent
muslims
for an act they have no personal
responsibility
on which they reject as a criminal
sinful act
fundamentally against the teachings of
islam
it should be noted that a number of
these islamophobic hate incidents in
greater manchester
were carried out on non-muslim black and
asian people
this fact reminded me that one only
to look at latest manifestations of
british far-right parties
to see how these groups have morphed
from spewing racist hatred
to an obsession with vilifying all
muslims
it's clear mr deputies uh deputy mayor
that some of these people and some
people in wider society
use the words black asian and
muslim synonymously
certainly it's not in doubt that when
most people hear the word
muslim the first image to appear in
their minds
their mind's eye is that of a black or
asian person
it's not difficult to see therefore how
a racist will also be an islamophobe
whether or not she or he is even aware
of this fact
and as such mr deputy mayor this motion
proposes that the council adopt
the definition of islamophobia published
last year
by the all-purpose
of british muslims that definition is
islamophobia is rooted in racism and it
is a type of racism
that targets expressions of muslimness
or perceived muslimness
i also call on the council to adopt the
examples of islamophobia outlined in the
motion
these are not an exhaustive but an
indicative list of the types of
islamophobia muslims experience during
their lives
all of us in this meeting all of us and
the vast majority of trafficked
residents
wish to live in peace harmony and
friendship with one another
and will therefore have no tolerance of
such displays of prejudice and
discrimination
the muslim population of trafford has
increased in recent decades
and i have no doubt that the 2021 census
will demonstrate a further increase
from the 7.9 of our population being
recorded in 2011 as muslims
it's imperative that majority protect
the rights
of minorities that mr deputy mayor
is one of the defining features of
modern democracy
something all of us should strive to
uphold
i know everyone here welcomes and values
the significant contribution that
trafford's muslims
make to our economic and social life
muslims are an
indispensable part of a diverse cohesive
bureau
muslims love living in trump
and our faith islam reminds us to live
in peace
and strive to fulfill our duty to make
positive contributions to our
neighborhoods
whilst taking our rightful place in the
life of the borough
i also wish to comment mr deputy mayor
on the shameful rise
in racism anti-semitism and islamophobia
within our major political parties an
important
point as political parties are at the
beating heart of trafford council
my muslim family friends and neighbors
have experienced both direct and
indirect islamophobia over the years its
negative impact on their mental and
physical well-being
and life opportunities cannot be
underestimated
as such i have been personally horrified
as have the majority of labour party
members
by the cases of anti-semitism that have
raised their ugly head in our party in
recent years
similarly islamophobia has also been
reported within the labour party
recently
with 25 of our muslim members reporting
in 2020
that they have experienced direct
islamophobia within the party
and 59 feeling they do not feel
well represented by the leadership of
the party
and what of traffic council members
ourselves
as far as i am aware and please correct
me if i'm wrong
we have two muslim members that's just
over three percent of the chamber
in 2021 this is simply not good enough
mr deputy mayor
suggested to me that we actually tried
to make a little bit of progress
uh this evening so if you could try and
uh tracy some of your
remains of your speech that would be i'd
be very grateful indeed
thank you very much certainly mr mayor
i think you'll gather the point i'm
trying to make is
when the 2021 census returns are
collated
we should be looking at having between 8
and 10 by
my estimation members reflecting
the muslim population there'll be some
in the conservative group
who may suspect that this motion was
tabled tonight as an opportunity
to attack some of the more gratuitous
examples of islamophobia
linked within its party members mps and
current labour
that is not my intention i'm someone who
believes in getting our own acting order
my focus is on the labour party rather
than the conservative party
and the potential for islamophobia
within the council functions and
services
i also want to bring members attention
to the large
genocide amendment to the trade bill
that was rejected by the government's uh
party
in parliament last week i was
particularly concerned about
that considering the power state of
muslims
in china i'm urged to ask you to wind up
now if you can thank you thank you very
much i will wind up on what i would like
members to do
is to contact graham brady mp to
encourage
him to vote for the amendment when it
next come to parliament
i will now close my final sentences
let's remember today on holocaust
memorial day
to strive to be the light in the dark
against prejudice and discrimination
wherever we find it in our own hearts
and minds first and foremost
and when we see it manifest itself in
the faces
words and deeds of those we share our
lives and work with
thank you mr mayor thank you not so long
done and for your forbearance on the
time restraints we have this evening um
the leader of the council is to second
the motion uh council
uh leader thank you mr deputy matt i
will second and reserve the right to
speak for the moment thank you
thank you leader i have uh just i
believe oh now i have no i now have
five six speakers in in the chat box um
i i i will ask them all to be very brief
no more than a minute and i would
phrase earlier than that that being a
human being i'm aware that there may
well be
a great deal of cross-party support for
this motion
so we'll begin with uh councillor minis
thank you mr deputy mayor um i'd like to
offer
my support on behalf of the liberal
democrat group
for this motion entirely having suffered
racism throughout my childhood years and
seeing it reduce and then rise again
uh clearly more needs to be done
fortunately schools are doing
all they can to educate our young people
to change
uh society for the better and racism of
all kinds needs to stop
and we all have our our duty and part to
play
and i would hope that everybody um in
their own homes and everywhere they go
um go you know in their workplaces
everything try to
reduce it it's i can't i don't know how
to explain the
the effect as it were but i i've had it
for a very long time thank you very much
thank you council and minister
councillor chilton
um one of the um most enjoyable aspects
of the
my 18 months as the mayor was the
opportunity to relaunch the community
cohesion forum
which again is a vehicle for
local leaders of different faiths and
religions to come together and discuss
issues of concern to their communities
and get to know each other better um i
do hope
mr mayor and this is directed to
councillor whitton the leader and to you
as hopefully the future chair of that
body
that that work will continue into the
future um that we can all uh get
together
and i do hope uh and i would like to pay
tribute
uh swallow mom um to trafford's muslim
community for their
um support and cooperation in that um
and to thank them for their hospitality
during my 18 months um in
many different uh scenarios uh not least
the book launched by as councillor
london's sister his notable ancestor
robert stanley which is very interesting
one of the first uh notable muslims in
greater manchester um
um thank you very much mr mayor please
thank you councillor chilton can we move
to council morgan for a minute
uh thank you mr deputy mayor um i'm more
than happy to support this motion
and for those who ask why we need it i
just asked them to look harder
um hijabs torn off muslim women at
universities spittings assaults
and just down the road from my ward um
the disgusting knife attack on a muslim
surgeon
outside the islamic center in hale um i
can speak as a minority in this chamber
um i've not had any discrimination i'm
not trying to pull any heart strings but
i can emphasize sometimes how comments
and jokes
and banter um can make you feel and stay
with you long after they've been made
um this bar is a fantastic place
integrated and diverse
um but it's not perfect and we need to
always be doing more and i think i can
really welcome this motion and i support
it heartily
thank you councilman morgan uh
councillor evans
thank you deputy mayor uh for once i
pretty much agree entirely with council
or london
and which probably surprises him as much
as me and there's just no
there's nowhere to go with this it's
certainly needed and it's
i think it's recognized as the odd line
change needed in it
by many bodies but i don't i think we're
splitting hairs at that point
uh i'll assure council london i've
already spoken to rmp
on the china issue and i'll happily take
a call from him and just uh
explain what where things are with
respect to that the whole group i
will be supporting this motion thank you
it's nice to have a level of agreement
after the previous motion so thank you
thank you thank you councillor evans
councillor coggins
i'll be very briefly again the green
party will of course be supporting this
motion as green
party have on scottish parliament and
and i believe elsewhere
and thank you for cancer london
a few words thank you from councillor
slater
uh thank you deputy mayor um
islamophobia along with all forms of
racism and a scourge on our society and
it's extremely worrying
that our prime minister has actually
engaged in some misplaced comments about
muslim women
so hopefully if as we agree this motion
and move
forward we can we can be a borrower that
we can be really proud of
we can be inclusive and our equality
strategy will be the building blocks
uh for for that moving forward so i
welcome this this motion thank you for
bringing it councillor london
thank you councillor slater i'm aware
that of butt may wish to have a few
very few words
thank you deputy mayor i'll be fairly
quick as well um i mean as a member of
the
vme community myself there are negative
attitudes out there
uh still existing and sometimes they
flare up when
uh incidents happen as uh council london
is already
mentioned and any any uh
support is always welcome to improve
matters and
and i think this motion goes a fair way
to do that uh
i do welcome it and support it myself as
well thank you thank you councillor bob
that's the last speaker now referring to
back to our leader
council weston do you wish to speak
before i asked
councillor london to sum up yeah thank
you
mr deputy mayor just extremely briefly
to welcome the all party support for
this there is
a particularly important aspect of this
motion
and which is to encourage the government
to um
also adopt the definition so i really
welcome that we have that support this
is a
serious serious issue and i'm very very
proud that everybody in the chamber has
contented to support for the motion i
think that it will be extremely
well received by our and local muslim
community that we've taken
this step um and i'm really really
pleased that it's moved forward thank
you
mr
thank you leader um and uh i'll now ask
councillor london to uh he has the right
of reply which i suspect will be very
brief given the support he's been given
to this man
thank you mr mayor uh just to say thank
you to all of the speakers and for their
positive
comments and working uh welcoming uh the
motion
uh let's get it passed tonight hopefully
unanimously
as we did with the uh international
memorial definition of anti-semitism a
couple of years ago
thank you thank you council london
rather than going to a vote on this to
save time
is it in order do we feel that we're
able to accept this motion
to
the third motion is headed council corps
spending power increase
and reliance on council tax increases
and is to be moved by
councillor ross please councillor ross
thank you
thank you mr deputy mayor the details
set out in this motion is necessary to
underline the situation facing councils
across the country
and exacerbated by the pressures
associated with covet 19.
in essence what this motion is seeking
is to ask the government to look again
at how much they approach
how they approach local government
finance
an increasing course enables us
support services services that so many
of our residents have
placed a very high value on however
we are right to question how this
increase is being funded
the government's own figures assume that
the vast majority of this increase in
course spending will be met through
increases to council tax
and the adult social care precept with
the government's own contribution being
around 13
there are several reasons why we want
the government to look again at their
contribution
the first being that providing financial
support through the revenue support
grant or equivalent
would allow the council to mitigate the
impact on local council taxpayers
another concern i have relates to the
proportion of our next net expenditure
funded by council tax
to put it simply the sip for resilience
index
suggests it is high risk to have a large
proportion of funding
coming from one source that is subject
to volatility
the way local government funding has
changed in recent years
has made this an inevitability for many
local authorities
and the introduction of direct support
from central government
would help diversify our funding base
and lower that risk
one of the main pressures evident to us
all is the
adult social care funding crisis this is
a crisis the government has failed to
address for far too many years now
and instead we've seen a peaceful
approach to funding via the adult social
care precept introduced five years ago
the government should be placing much
greater value on people receiving care
and working in the care sector
and we urge ministers to bring forward
proposals as soon as possible
finally we're calling on the government
to deliver the fair funding review
a review that acknowledges poverty and
inequality and also the impact council
tax has on lower income households
thank you mr deputy mayor
[Music]
thank you councillor ross uh the leader
of the council will second the motion
secondly mr marine again i'll reserve
the right thank you
right thanks thank you
um my i ask
for people to put in the chat box
whether they wish to speak
at the moment i have nobody right
i'll give you one or two moments um
anyway we can move first of all to
councillor morgan who wishes to speak
anyone else please note and we're going
to have to
restrict the time so if i interrupt you
you will have to wind up very promptly
after that thank you
councillor morgan uh thank you very much
mr deputy mayor i'm going to keep this
brief because i know um
the agenda is pretty tight tonight um
but i really do think this is unfair
motion
um i think the government throughout
this crisis is supportive local um
councils over seven billion
pounds in additional funding in this
year alone in addition to
um for other examples such as deferring
like government councils to defer
business rate payments 4 billion and
leveling up funds uh 3.6 billion
for the um towns fund and
for the next financial year the
government is boosting council budgets
by
2.2 billion up by 4.5 percent
well above the rate of inflation and
indeed when you compare it to wales
which labour have been in government for
since um
the late 90s um welsh local authorities
will see their budgets up by
16 less than england um next year
mr deputy mayor this is a part of that
motion which doesn't address the
challenges of trafford and is
it's an inconsistent approach um with
what labour are doing when they
are in government in wales and i ask all
councillors to reject it
thank you thank you councillor morgan
the next speaker councillor coggins
thank you
thank you councillor and uh thank you
chair the green party group will be
supporting this motion tonight
and since becoming cancer and really
getting my head around
the details of council finances i have
been really quite
shocked at to be honest what the
previous conservative administration did
to this borough and sometimes residents
say to me they
go around and it seems like the potholes
are worse here than in other areas it
seems like our services are are are you
know more badly hit by austerity than
elsewhere
and i i used to think that that was an
illusion that
you know that the grass was greener
elsewhere but i've learned that actually
no
we've prided ourselves for many years on
being a low council tax authority and
having the lowest council tax in greater
manchester
leaving us with a very very low level of
income
because our council taxes capped we
can't even increase that now that we
have a different administration
that meant we have extremely low levels
of reserves much lower than similar
authorities
so very little to fall back on in a
crisis as we've seen this year
and of course we've had extremely low
levels of
input from local from national
government down 60
across the country since 2010. the only
option left to local councils is
commercial investment which now the
conservative party is not even
supporting here even though there seems
to be
very few options left so um yeah i
really do support this
this this motion and really an
opportunity to
to well to to ask our conservative
colleagues how can you defend
this and how how can you have left the
people that have trafford in this
desperate financial situation given your
reputation as a party your fiscal
responsibility
thank you thank you councillor coggins
and move on to councillor freeman please
thank you mr deputy mayor i'm going to
come straight back at council morgan
i've seen the traffic conservative
facebook page where you talk about core
spending power
you imply on your page that the
government have increased our core
spending power by 8.04 million pounds
you imply that that money has been given
to trafford
by your government you mislead it is
typical of
your party and i fully support what
council ross has said
yes we can increase our core spending
power by 8.04 million
but 80 percent of that will come from
raising
council tax and putting the burden on
our local residents
it's time for a rethink and i think you
should be apologizing
for the stuff that you put out on your
trafford facebook
conservative page thank you mr deputy
mayor
thank you councillor freeman uh the next
speaker i have in the box of chat box is
councillor evans
uh thank you thank you deputy mayor um
it must be a typo actually in the motion
you were caught you are calling for an
increase from the government for
from 292 million to 1.92 billion a
500 increase i can't even
conceive how you arrived at that just to
pick up on some of the things that
councilman morgan said
4.6 billion in on ring friends grant
funding 1.1 billion to protect care
homes
300 million for local test and trade
services 500 million in surge funding
233 million to prevent vulnerable
families going hungry
95 million to support rough sleepers and
it certainly did take the government's
intervention
not the mayor of greater manchester to
solve the rough sleeping problem not
that it's solved but to at least start
to tackle it
and 500 million in all the funding
we won't be supporting this motion and a
call for 500
increase unless it's a typo i'm shocked
excuse the lack of video i couldn't get
it to come on thank you mr deputy mayor
thank you uh councillor evans and i'll
forgive you for the lack of video
that's the last name that i have in the
chat box so we'll move to
uh councillor uh western i believe i'll
deserve the right to
speak at this point am i correct uh yeah
thank you mr white mayor and perhaps i
can uh deputy mayor other
perhaps i can begin by explaining to
councillor evans precisely
why the uplift is as it is and that is
because it is intended to say
that at a time of a global pandemic
at a time when people are being
furloughed at a time when people are
losing their jobs at a time
when as we have already heard this
evening hardship for our residents is
increasing
the spending power referred to is
largely coming from council tax
and that is the difference between what
is being allocated
directly from government and what is
being indirectly allowed to us
through council tax and to councillor
morgan when he lists the
um additional spend required he talks
about the support
we have he knows that's not enough he
knows
that we were promised whatever it takes
and he knows we've not
received that 37 million pound budget
gap
next year now that we are having to
address 50 million pounds
spent over our allocated budget this
year
37 million pounds is 20 percent of our
revenue budget gap
you know we've not received enough and
when you speak of the support we have
received
you failed to say that not only has that
come through council tax but it has come
through other
less than savory means because of a
consistent
approach of austerity and hammering
local government as the enemy
that leaves us in a position where that
is largely coming
from a further one percent on the adult
social care preset
and freezing staff pay and when we have
reached a point as an administration
when the way to balance our budget is to
freeze staff
pay because the government tells us that
that liberates funding
it is a disgrace they are key workers
most of them
in a pandemic leading a magnificent
response and that is your government's
approach
to how we balance our books so that's
why this motions here and that's why i
would encourage all members to support
it thank you mr mayor
thank you leader councillor weston um we
moved
to councillor ross
to to sum up hopefully very briefly
because we have
three more motions one of which as you
know has got a couple of amendments to
it
thank you very much uh mr deputy mayor
um
i think the conservatives have um have
misunderstood the
the motion i mean they talk about the
growth in course spending but
they failed as has been pointed out by
councillor freeman and council weston
to point out that um the majority of
that is
expected to come from council tax and
social care precept increases
and it's also all very well reeling off
the the money that's supporting
or has come to the local councils over
the course of the year however
as at this period eight budget
monitoring report we are still
looking at a um a shortfall of 8 million
pounds were it not for the fact that we
could defer
our deficits in council tax and business
rates to future years
it's also disappointing that the
conservatives did made no mention
of adult social care the pressure that
that
service is under and how we seriously
need to get a proper
funding formula sorted for that at an
international level
i'd like to thank councillor coggins for
her support i i i
could completely agree with with
everything she says
um local government finance remains in
a dire state across councils all over
england and wales and we really do need
to look seriously
as to how we fund local councils so that
they continue
delivering those services that local
residents
value so much fairly
to those local residents so we would ask
we would plea for the conservatives to
change their minds and support this
motion and send a message
to the government this evening thank you
thank you
councillor ross um
so we now go to a vote so please um
the poll is open
please make sure you voted and press
submit at the bottom of the page
i'm still waiting to see a screen with a
result
from governance
it's about to arrive right with that i
can announce that that motion
has been carried so we moved to motion
6d
this evening concerns gmp special
measures
and is to be moved by councillor brophy
please thank you
deputy mayor may i make a statement
can i just ask the mayor to clarify the
order in which the amendments and
speakers are going to be taken
just from sorry to interrupt you i do
apologize
um uh councillor evans which is to make
a declaration before
discussion begins on this item
uh thank you deputy mayor i've been
advised by the monitoring officer that i
should
at least and well make everybody aware
that my wife is one of the prospective
uh mayoral candidates uh for the gm
mayor position
thank you thank you councillor evans
apologies councillor brophy the floor is
yours
before i start speaking i just want to
clarify
what order the amendments have been
taken just so we're all clear from the
beginning about
what the speeches will be on all the
different amendments
you will move your motion it will be
seconded
then we have the labor amendment
and depending etc and beyond that we
have the conservative amendment that's
the order
in which things will be taken okay
okay in moving this motion is it three
minutes i just want to get that right
from the beginning
to get through all the three motions
tonight including these amendments we're
talking about you know
not very much more than two minutes in
terms of speeches particularly if you've
got someone seconding
and they wish to speak counselor broken
thank you okay
in moving this motion i want to pay
tribute to the many officers and staff
at greater manchester police who carry
out their duties with dedication and
professionalism
the challenges they have faced in recent
years have been unprecedented
the appalling attack at manchester arena
in 2017
shocked the city but gmp voted the
occasion of bravery
and the response was praised by people
around the world
kovic 19 presents new challenges to
policing
now more than ever we see the value of
community-based approaches through our
local pcsos as local councillors we
should all welcome the police federation
reports on policing in england and wales
because it places the role of policing
in the context of local communities and
seeks
to repurpose the role of modern policing
in a way that's less reliant on reactive
police work
instead focusing on community driven
preventative policing
so despite the hard work of officers and
staff this report indicates
a crisis of leadership in our city's
policing
over 80 000 crimes unrecorded that's
220 crimes each day an estimated one in
four violent crimes are included in
these figures
these are not individual failings or
one-off mistakes they are systematic
failings stemming from a lack of
leadership
ultimately the responsibility to drive
change rests with andy burnham
that's why it's right this motion calls
upon him to update this council with a
clear action plan
which will bring policing back to the
standards our residents expect
politics is a changing landscape but the
law is impartial
and liberal democrats believe that the
responsibility for policing should sit
with the
not with the politicians but with the
officers themselves and with their
independent inspectors when the metro
mayor was introduced to incorporate
the responsibilities of a police and
crime commissioner
andy burnham knew that he was getting
into this
yet on his watch gmp has failed to
improve
the situation has become more severe
unrecorded and criminals are going
uninvestigated
i will close my remarks and by saying we
support this motion and we look forward
to working constructively
with gmp as they move this forward in
these processes
thank you very much councillor brophy uh
is the motion seconded
i am seconding and may i reserve the
right reply
elsewhere thank you very much indeed so
we move at this point i believe to the
first amendment
which is in the hands of the labour
group and is to be proposed by
councillor freeman
uh thank you mr deputy mayor in moving
this amendment to
an interest in that i receive an
occupational pension from greater
manchester police
i propose the amendment not because i
disagree with the content of the motion
but because of its inaccuracies i note
with amusement
that the liberal democrats refer to cuts
from policing from 2016.
they must adept in there cannot be
allowed to rewrite history themselves to
suit themselves
they along with the conservatives in
this chamber played a major part in
allowing austerity to take root in this
country
as part of the coalition government from
2012 to 15
and the amendment now reflects that the
amendment acknowledges all of the
current issues that are faced by gmp
and the need for our residents to have
confidence in that service but i do
think it's important
we all pay tribute to the officers and
staff of gnp
who continue to perform their duties
with professionalism and dedication
despite sometimes
overwhelming pressures that have been
brought to bear on them as a result of
the cuts they have suffered
in the name of austerity and the further
pressures they have faced dealing with
this pandemic
now no doubt the party opposite will
stand and shout that's the conservatives
about the considerable investment they
claim is now being made in the police
service
the recruitment of 20k new officers but
i just say to them mr deputy mayor
when you've had 215 million wiped from
your budget since 2012 by their
government
it's it's difficult to come back from
that and their hands are therefore
all over the current difficulties faced
by gmp
and before they start blaming the mayor
of greater manchester his lack of
scrutiny
of gnp i say to them the current system
of scrutiny
is the one that their government
introduced while still hanging onto the
purse strings
which they have pulled extremely tight
the moral of the story mr deputy mayor
is that you cannot have it both ways i
commend the amendment
uh this amendment the most demanded
motion to council members
thank you mr deputy mayor thank you very
much councillor freeman
is that amendment seconded
seconded uh mr deputy mayor and um
i'll reserve the right thank you right
at this point i'd ask is anyone wishing
to
speak on this amendment other than uh
councillor freeman and councillor
whitten was already
reserved the right i'll go back to him
if there isn't anybody
there's nobody in the chat room now
we've now got councillor
right okay council chilton very briefly
you've probably got no more than a
minute
thank you i don't mean
there is one politician who is
responsible
for the shambles that he has presided
over the past four years
it isn't the officer's fault they have
been let down by
the person who should not have been
scrutinizing greater manchester police
he is responsible
for the running of it and that is andy
burnham and he should resign
now thank you mr deputy mayor thank you
councillor chilton the next speaker
councillor coggins
thank you i'll be brief um we support
the liberal democrat
motion and i want to start as well by
thanking our police for the
their services uh more difficult than
ever in the current um
in the current conditions and and given
10 years of austerity
like everyone else i was horrified by
the stories of 80 000 crimes not being
recorded
and we do need clarity and we need to
have answers from andy burnham and i
have spoken to the leader about
um we did discuss andy burnham coming
and
explaining and discussing this at
traffic council which is something i
very much support
and we will support the labour amendment
if i can briefly mention that so i don't
have to speak again
and these problems are fundamentally
caused by austerity
and we have a situation in great
manchester we have a sort of partial
devolution
where we have devolution of a limited
range of decision making
but not revenue raising powers so we
have a sort of devolution of blame where
westminster
can under fund services and then blame
the the local situation
as we see with local government as well
so we will be supporting at the original
amen the original motion
and the labor amendment but not the
conservative amendment thank you
[Music]
thank you councillor coggins councillor
kerry
thank you mr deputy mayor the policing
is the only area of public policy
that the labour mayor andy berman has
executive responsibility for and he has
failed
he should resign he has spent more time
pandering to the press than his role
thank you mr deputy mayor thank you
councillor carey councillor
evans thank you deputy mayor well we all
pay tribute to our police officers
and and it's truly a tough job that they
undertake
on our behalf and to protect our society
but i don't believe there is a single
piece of criticism directed at
our offices zoe billingham
um who wrote the report there wasn't one
comment on
funding it was all about leadership
and as we all know leadership comes from
the top
and the top of this tree is the gmat
andy burnham the mayor is ultimately
responsible for policing in gm
four years four reports
and a constant decline not at one point
only at the very end as he picked it up
and said oh
you know what we should do something
about this and he turns to the people of
greater manchester
to fund his failings the mess
should do the right thing and he should
resign
thank you mr deputy man thank you
councillor evans we've got another
speaker councillor morgan
uh thank you mr mayor i don't think the
mayor is a bad person
he certainly learned some media skills
in his lifetime in uh
frontline politics um but he has not
prioritized his role as police
and crime commissioner it was five years
ago the inspector at razor initial
concerns what was the mayor
and the deputy mayor he appointed been
doing in the last four years
when have they been in these positions
80 000 crimes missed last year
one in five crimes one in four violent
crimes even more shockingly
i agree with councillor brophy um that's
where i would say that
um but andy byrne is ultimately
responsible and he's ultimately
responsible he should do the right thing
and it is time for him to resign
thank you councillor morgan um we moved
now back to
councillor whittam who reserve the right
to speak do you wish to speak at this
point sir thank you councillor whitaker
yeah thank you mr deputy mayor i mean
just just briefly i mean i second the
labour amendment to the to motion
because it is important that this
council
accurately reflects what's happened to
police funding over the last
uh 10 years and fully understands that
the consequences of policing policy over
that
same um period i mean i i don't like
saying this just before i go
go into that i don't like saying this
but i do think it takes some goal
to be calling for local labor
politicians to resign
the day after we reach such a grim
milestone as a country yesterday
we think about the the appalling record
of this government in responding to the
pandemic over the last nine
ten months and not a single government
minister has resigned the time
that i'm aware of and back to the the
labour amendment the the cut in the the
central government grant to greater
manchester police that councilor freeman
has outlined to us
and that is set out in the amendment to
the motion has had devastating
consequences it has meant that greater
manchester has two thousand fewer police
officers and 1 000 fewer support staff
and it has drastically reduced other
essential policing resources
let's be absolutely clear that the
proportion of these cuts
that were introduced prior to 2015 were
signed off and doors supported by the
liberal democrats
and as part of the coalition government
and i think that that's why we wanted to
amend the the motion on these lines uh
no yeah thank you deputy mayor that's
that's me done thank you
right at this point we go back to
councillor brophy as
a right of reply on these debates
concerning the amendment before the
amendment
is put to the vote councillor brophy
on muting there
so i think as has been raised by people
in the debate in this context there are
serious questions to be asked of andy
burnham's competence
when he is prepared to place failing
police forces into our high schools
this is what he proposes to do under the
school-based police officers scheme
and it's been rightly met by strong
opposition from communities
social workers and the national
education union here in trafford
so i think there are fundamental
questions here and i agree with the
points that people have made
i do think there's an issue of trust um
here and if
um people die nine nine nine there's a
there's a one in four chance that their
issue that they raise won't ever be
recorded that's something that's quite
serious and needs to be addressed
thank you councillor brophy i think that
concludes the discussion on
the uh the labor-based amendment so
at this point we go to put that labour
amendment to the vote so again
please vote and press submit at the
bottom of your screen
so we can do this as quickly as
needed possible be ready
right i can report that the uh the
amendment
one has been passed uh so
for the time being at least that becomes
a substantive motion we now move to the
the second amendment um which i'm going
to understand
has been circulated to all members
although if anyone is wishing for it to
be read i understand it can be
so if we are silent on that one i'll
assume that it is not going to be read
and the amendment is therefore uh
the it was in the hands initially of
councillor evans has given notices at
this amendment
council evans is it you proposing it or
is it in the hands of another
member councillor proposing council of
god thank you so councillor
is proposing the second amendment thank
you
[Music]
i'm sorry yes and you will have a minute
am i speaking uh to say this yeah i
think everybody's
read this uh amendment so can i
just say that you know we've uh we've
made all the points that we wanted to
make on this one
so i mean there was announcement by the
home secretary that policing will
receive a 15.8 billion pound 20 21 22
638 million increased last year so
when we say that the uh the amendment
you know
there's no investment being made there
has been investment made but
uh performance has fallen short it's
from the leadership
but so if i could say just that if you
followed the amendment
uh and i i judge everybody to support it
thank you councillor but so is that a
conservative group amendment seconded
i'll second it mr mayor and and and
speak at this point if i may
um the lib liberal democrat motion
failed to address where the failure lies
the labor of motion
attempts to divert blame and from
the labor pcc and there the inspector
was clear
our mayor has failed he had one job he
failed
the mayor should do the right thing and
resign
thank you
[Music]
thank you councillor evans i'm looking
in the chat room and you can see that
first of all councillor freeman wishes
to speak on this
amendment thank you councillor freeman
thank you mr deputy
i'll be brief i have never seen such a
load of
naked political opportunism operating
here with
the conservative politician calling for
a resignation
perhaps they would like to look to their
own government first for some
resignations
before they come calling out labour
politicians in greater manchester
there is a difference between
operational responsibility
and scrutiny it's the scrutiny system
that's at fault here you set it up your
hands
are all over the problems that gmp
currently have
i ask members to reject their amendment
thank you
right we now have three more speakers
wishing to speak we're
rapidly running out of time uh and i'm
aware obviously that much has already
been said on both sides of this debate
so to be very very brief uh councillor
myers
we can't hear you i'm sorry
apologies for that mr deputy mayor i've
got it right now i think
last december greater manchester police
admitted that they failed to record over
80 000 crimes
in a year the equivalent of 22 of the
crimes actually committed
a greater concern perhaps is the higher
proportion of violent crimes that were
hidden
and closed without proper investigation
in many cases
files were closed because the victim
allegedly refused to give evidence in
court
however the inspector joey billingham
said in too many of these cases the
force didn't properly record
evidence that the victim supported this
decision
in 2016 the inspectorate pointed out a
serious lack of
organization and leadership within
greater manchester
nothing was said about finance or
money coming into greater manchester
police it was leadership and
organization
thank you accountants that's a minute
thank you very much for that
contribution we'll have to move to
councillor thomas
thank you again mr deputy mayor i'd just
like to
speak out against this uh amendment
obviously
they are just looking to do the pointing
finger blame game
as they're doing with the pandemic at
the moment without looking at the root
cause of the problem which is
the massive massive underfunding of the
police
since 2010 thank you mr mayor
thank you thank you councillor thomas uh
councillor
dr karen barclay uh thank you miss uh
thank you
mr decker um eight eighty thousand
um crimes were committed as um were
sorry
eighty thousand crimes were not recorded
across greater manchester
and that actually equated to about eight
thousand crimes in trafford alone
and that is eight thousand victims who
have been really incredibly badly let
down
happy councillor barkley i'm being asked
to ask you to bring
new information to the debate if you
cannot then i
please will you wrap up very quickly
well i can't say thank you
and the next speaker uh councillor
councillor weston
councillor andrew weston thank you
mr deputy mayor i think there is a
really important point here for all of
us to
recognize which is that the residents of
greater manchester have been let down
um and we need to put this right i don't
um support calls for
a resignation here and actually i think
um it would do all of us well to
remember
that the um america to manchester is up
for re-election this year and it will be
residents who have their say i have to
say not a single member of the public
has contacted me to ask for andy's
resignation but i'm sure he will be
scrutinized
as part of that process and so till will
the record of former councillor laura
evans the conservative candidate
who served on the pcp for one year 2017
to 2018
and never once raised performance issues
we know that it is clear from the
minutes
so i look forward to that election and
then we can all move forward because
that is the way
to unseat politicians when you are
unhappy we will be rejecting this
amendment
thank you thank you councillor at
western the
the the right to reply before we take
the vote is actually with councillor
brophy but we've had a huge amount of
debate i wonder
if does she actually want to see
anything perhaps not
so in that case we'll move to the vote
for this
second amendment so please go to your
polls
and vote and submit as previously
so the amendment the second amendment is
lost so basically we now have
the original motion amended as per the
labor group that is the substantive
motion
uh i believe that we've had quite enough
debate in every direction so far on this
topic
and i would propose that with the
council as with the members agreement
we now go to the vote on the amended
which is now substantive motion
so are we okay with that we're going to
the vote anyway
so you've now got a further polling box
on that amended motion so it's the
original motion of mended by the labor
group
and i'm still waiting for the box to
tell me what the result is
we'll get there and so the amended the
motion as amended by the labor group
is passed we move on to motion 6e the
next motion
concerns tax relief for season ticket
travel
which i understand is to be moved by
councillor minis
and we are probably looking at not much
more than a minute
for any speaker at all so i hope your
prepared
scripts can be amended very very quickly
thank you
thank you mr deputy mayor i'll keep it
very short
um so the caveat restrictions have
sparked debate about what our public
transport system should look like
as as we consider how much we want to
return to the old normal
and how much we want to find a better
way to do things the noticeable
improvement in air quality has led many
trafford residents
to ask how can we keep our air cleaner
especially now that car journeys have
increased once again
public transport may be less attractive
whilst vaccination is still in progress
but i believe this council must think of
ways to encourage people to get back
onto public transport in the future
we allow tax-free purchasing of bicycles
to to get to work
by employers why not public transport
passes um so the liberal democrats
motion paves the way for an approach
that could help with this thank you very
much
thank you council of menace is that
motion seconded
absolutely seconded right to reserve the
rights thank you
to the council of new gross uh it's
proposed and
who wishes to speak on this sorry i just
need to
goodness gracious my last two words
are very quick comments today
that
i'll be very fast on this just say the
leg will be supporting this
uh motion i think obviously during the
pandemic uh
there's been a mass numbers of people
not able to use it and
once we get out the pandemic we need to
get people back on it
it's concerning and anything that can
actually support that
but we'll be really positive we need
some initiatives that'll actually do it
and
we're looking for all sorts of support
initiatives i think this is fits that
role very much so
i think it's got to be a priority and i
hope that we this won't be passed by all
members but supported nationally as well
that we need to really turn public
transport around and catch a way of
doing it
this in itself will actually be a real
encouragement and given people's income
has gone down dramatically during the
pandemic
i think something like this will
actually really assist in that matter
thank you mr mayor
thank you councillor i'd say the next
speaker councillor morgan
thank you mr deputy mayor again i'll i
would keep very brief in support of this
i mean as
somebody who does this as his job in
terms of calculating some of these
things for um for trains um i
i think it's really really supportive i
think i'd just like to put a pointer i
mean i have actually raised this with
the mayor on on a different hat that he
was wearing that
um i do wonder about how we support the
metrolink
um going forward um in that where people
might not be working in the office every
day and they might work one day a week
about whether the annual season ticket
is
um going to work for that um but yeah
thank you very much
thank you councillor morgan and as the
council has representative on the gmci
accounts and audit committee i can
assure you there's a great
discussion about the metro link um
moving on to
um councillor evans
next speaker thank you thank you deputy
mayor
um i welcome the opportunity to uh agree
with boris johnson
um and without a doubt it would give the
lowest paid
and more disposable income which is not
a bad thing it would support
our economy it will support our public
transport and it will support the
lower paid as well as everybody else but
specifically so 100
support this thank you council minister
bringing it
that's the conclusion of the speakers in
the chat box does council and minister
want to actually
say anything in terms of summing up or
council new gross
who hasn't had the opportunity to
actually speak yet really
i think i'd like to s to welcome warmly
welcome the cross party support for this
motion
um it's good for the residents of
trafford it's good for the
travel um and it's good for the climate
for the climate emergency we have
i think this is a fantastic move thank
you all
thank you councillor new cross council
and minister conclude
just a thank you to everybody thank you
very much
as has been said i think this is a cross
party in
favor of this so we don't need to go to
a poll can we actually uh just take a
vote by uh
or indicating verbally i i
i i i i i i
i im
and this evening concerns the
government's response to the basic needs
of students
schools and colleges during the pandemic
and is to be moved by councillor london
please
sorry again there will be some pretty
heavy time restrictions on speeches for
this particular motion thank you
council london thank you deputy mayor i
want to start by thanking all those
working in education
to keep earlier setting schools and
colleges open since march
last year the vast majority have
remained open throughout the pandemic
to teach the children of key workers and
vulnerable students
including in the holidays where required
now
by the nature of our profession teachers
rise to new challenges
every single day the parents know that
why does society know that
mr williamson our secretary of state for
education
seems to forget that particularly
encouraged parents to report an
experience of poor online teaching
recently
he got his response from the 10 000
emails from all over the country from
parents expressing their gratitude
to the quality of online teaching their
children have experienced
since last year mr deputy mayor we were
let down monumentally by the slow and
cavalier response of the prime minister
to the pandemic
it's now universally recognized that a
firm
lockdown was required weeks before it
came in the uk
that's why yesterday we reached a
mortality of a hundred thousand covered
related deaths it's a catastrophe for us
all
we're let down by gavin williamson's
lack of consultation with professional
bodies
and education unions from the start of
the pandemic till now
the provision of timely communication
and guidance to schools and colleges
by the department for education has been
a joke
leaving head teachers and staff
scrambling around to come up with
quick fixes often on their own after
receiving the government's ill-for-out
dick tax
the perhaps best example or should i say
the worst most
ridiculous example was the prime
minister
sending children mr deputy mayor
children were talking about back to
school
and that afternoon that very afternoon
telling us that we had to close them
imagine how many people were infected as
a result of that utterly reckless act
so we've been let down by gavin williams
and we've been let down
by the prime minister and yet here we
are at the end of january
2021 with still in a period of
consultation on this year's
coming exams after last year's fiasco
i cannot stand up in front of my
children and tell them
what is coming down the line in three
months outrageous
we talk about resignation i'm not
prepared to wait mr mayor
four years and i'll ask is this muslim
second secretary
he needs to resign now for the sake of
the children
thank you mr mayor for your patience
thank you councillor london is this
motion secondly
yes uh deputy mayor i'm going to second
it
thank you councillor because i can a
recent poll
found that 92 percent of teachers
thought that gavin williamson should
resign
i'm surprised it's this low and i can
only assume the other 8
were too tired to take the right box i
believe sir graham brady has told the
prime minister that
school children have become the
forgotten victims of the pandemic
with the gulf between the most
disadvantaged children and their peers
growing day by day
here's morgan asked mr williamson last
week why he had consistently failed over
half a million children on the it roll
out
you can tell the world has turned upside
down when i find myself agreeing
with graham brady and ps morgan but
they're not wrong on this
gavin is consistent he's consistently
terrible
and the government doesn't seem to make
think it matters but it does matter
with children are suffering from mental
health parents from the verge of a
breakdown
today we've heard that schools may go
back on the 8th of march
but we've been promised this that the
crisis will be over by christmas by the
summer by track and trace when the
vaccine's working
how do we even know and i get it's
difficult and i know we have to follow
the data in the science
but education is so important to our
children our families and our future
that we need to be led by a lion
not this incompetent mr flip-flop thank
you
thank you councillor carter we now have
people account members wishing to speak
and i will take them
in order i believe councillor kerry
is first to speak uh thank you mr deputy
mayor
um the people of trafford have been let
down by this labor
uh group that's why i can't support this
motion
they need to get their own educational
policies in order before telling the
government what to do
as discussed repeatedly at planning
committee
and executive just this week they are
running out of school places
in some parts of sale there are no
school places
and they have no pupil play strategy in
place
they need to sort out the basics instead
of wasting time on motions like this
the people of trafford are being let
down thank you mr deputy mayor
thank you councillor carey councillor
minis
sorry i've managed to amnesia thank you
um
uh mr deputy mayor um i'm absolutely in
support of this
um and i'm pretty sure that i think most
people
who are parents with children home
learning will understand
and the schools close suddenly last year
no idea when they're going to reopen
parents didn't have the equipment to
cater for their child
to try and teach the children online um
affluent families didn't even have it
then they do now
the less affluent don't and the poor
definitely don't um
the email from mr billy at wellington
school those that have children at
wellington school will uh
will have got that email absolutely sums
it up to a t and the man is not
political whatsoever
and i'll be in support of this i think
the government have done an awful job of
it and uh
i would call for resignation of gavin
thank you
thank you councillor minis councillor
heinz please
thank you uh mr deputy mayor um i just
want to take
exception really with the comments of
councillor kerry because
um there are no children in trafford
that have been left without a school
place
and um and there is a plan in place um
to support our children locally and but
nationally behind
every statistic um that we hear every
dire statistic that
that we hear um is a child whose chances
in life are being diminished
and by the lack of a meaningful plan
from gavin williams and from governments
many of those children will never
recover
um although i'm sure
that there are certainties that lie
ahead there is
so much that we already know and have
known for a very long time
the first lockdown happened a year ago
in march and we've known since then that
there were significant numbers of
children
who didn't have the i.t to learn from
home we knew last year that the
curriculum was being disrupted and that
children were losing so much of their
learning
and we knew that the exams this year as
well as last would be disrupted
but the response from gavin williamson
and the governments has been chaotic
and confusing and children are paying
the price
the schools here locally have been
amazing and in trafford i know how hard
had teachers and teachers have worked
to plan adapt and can you bring your
remarks to a close if possible
no problem um in order to avert a crisis
for a generation of children and young
people
which will turn into a crisis for the
future of our country
we really do need the secretary of state
and the whole of the government to take
responsibility
and put a clear plan in place now thank
you mr deputy mayor
thank you councillor heinz and next uh
move to council
western leader thank you mr deputy mayor
um
council heinz has covered the fact that
all of our children are catered for
councillor kerry should realize also not
only that that is the case when he is a
teacher himself
the planning committee is not the place
to be raising those issues because it's
not a material consideration
in planning terms so it's deeply
disappointing if he's taking those
debates
into the planning committee but the fact
of the matter is that i will accept no
criticism
and accusation that we are failing
children it is
this council who stood up the
distribution of free school meal
vouchers at
no notice at all this council who
responded to marcus rashford's campaign
this council who were messed around by
government will the funding be there yes
or no
and this council that is having to beg
for laptops from the business community
because of the absolutely disgusting
digital deficit that we see
that is impacting on our child's
education this council has stepped up
throughout this pandemic
we will continue to do so the education
secretary
has failed gavin williamson must go
thank you mr deputies thank you
councillor weston
uh councillor evans uh thank you mr
deputy mayor thank you for your time
keeping during this meeting up i see
it's been difficult
um it's clear there's been some issues
there's no doubt about that
and i actually seriously sat down with
this motion to try and amend it to see
if we could arrive at something
practical
but it's such a rambling three-page
motion that achieves nothing
other than has a pop for the sake of
having a pot
so we will not be supporting this motion
thank you councillor evan so we go back
to councillor london who has the right
to
sum up and reply to all the comments
made uh
on the floor the deputy mayor council
london has
been kicked out and is asking if he can
be let back in please
the governance team can try and get
council along them back on board
um
yeah if not can councillor carter sum up
um
whilst we're waiting for him to get
through the door thank you
councilman carter okay well i think it's
really clear
um you know gavin williamson has lost
the confidence of parents
of children of teachers of heads
and it's time for him to go so we're
calling for gavin williamson to resign
thank you i think that's uh that's an
adequate summing up of what's
been said uh across the floor so i think
we now go to a vote on this final motion
of the night
so the pole is open
i know
this is worse than strictly
right into the screen right i can
announce that the motion
uh the final motion of the night is past
is carried uh thank you very much indeed
um so that is the end of our meeting i
thank you all for your attendance
hope you enjoy the rest of your evening
i look forward to councillor walsh being
back with us
for the next council meeting uh which is
the budget one in february
in the meantime i'll leave you with a
thought that i had what was described as
a substantial meal
at two o'clock after the holocaust
ceremony it was by the way of a scotch
egg
some tomatoes and coleslaw and i'm going
home for the rest of my food
today now and i wish you all a very good
night and i hope to see you all soon
uh not just on zoom thank you very much
indeed everybody
thank you deputy mayor thank you mr left
have a good evening